a vengers endgame is written and
directed by the Russo brothers and stars
so many people this is the culmination
of a ton of different storylines all
coalescing into a gigantic finale so
after the devastating events of infinity
war where Thanos wiped out half of all
life in the universe
the remaining Avengers are scrambling to
hopefully find a way to set things right
in the universe once again before I get
any farther than the review I do want to
give a big thank you to Dollar Shave
Club they are the sponsor for this video
and I'm proud to have them as a sponsor
and to be a club partner with them so
thank you very much to them stay tuned -
after the review to learn a little bit
more about them I'm always weary of
films like Avengers endgame for multiple
reasons one they're very difficult to
talk about in a spoiler-free review
which is what this is and don't worry
I'll room nothing of course I won't even
hint at things as many professional
outlets already have but the other thing
is that these films come with so much
hype to the point where I have basically
learned to turn my brain off from that
hype I don't listen to theories I don't
listen to ideas that other people might
have I tend to not even read what the
plot is and I don't watch too much
trailers or clips or anything I just try
to stay away because hype can ruin a
movie and so whenever a film like this
comes around I try to be as disconnected
from it as possible and that's my way of
honoring the filmmakers and the writers
and hoping that you know I'm
experiencing a film with them that they
wanted me to see rather than hoping it
goes in a billion different directions
that I have already cooked up in my
brain even though they were never
planning to do that in the first place
and I'm happy to say this was a highly
satisfying film that brought tons of
storylines to a fantastic conclusion and
despite being three hours long really
didn't feel like it it felt about as
long as infinity war did
it's a beefy runtime obviously and there
will be many people who have things to
say about that and complain about that
and focus on the runtime but there were
just so many things they had to find a
way to present an honor in this film and
I can understand that two and a half
hours just probably wasn't enough
because they wrote themselves in a
corner at the end of infinity war
because you're in this place where
you're like how are they going
get out of this and was serialized
entertainment you're going to have to
continue this story and they need an
entire first act to really deal with
that and sometimes that first act can
feel a little slow purposefully and when
I say slow I don't necessarily mean that
as a bad thing
it's a very somber first act you're you
you feel like there's desperation this
is not a feeling you normally get in a
superhero film usually there's lots of
punching and it's really entertaining
and there's plenty of that in this movie
but this film takes a long time to make
you feel like you're watching regular
people not just superheroes the Avengers
in this movie feel the most human they
ever have after the ending of an
infinity war when you realized how much
of them could be expendable when it came
to the MC use decisions picking up here
really does make them feel like normal
people which is extremely refreshing
they're not doing superhero stuff the
whole movie they feel like they're
they're really desperate like they're
scrambling for a really anything that
they can get their hands on and so in
that way there's an urgency in almost
every scene which is a writers dream
when you feel like your characters are
in a place where they are always
constantly in motion towards some goal
and it feels like they have no hope of
the whole time that's really exciting
the second act picks up considerably in
the action department with a structure
that I actually predicted I never once
publicly predicted it so it's not a
spoiler for me to say that but I just in
my head I was like I think they might do
this and they did but it wasn't like I
was like oh I guess that I was happy
because I wanted them to do that and I
wanted to see what that could bring
about and I was really pleased with what
they do and that's all I'll say
but you came to this movie for the third
act and it delivers it's just an hour of
insanity it's fucking awesome and the
final action set piece is honestly movie
magic it's everything you expect to see
when you pay money for a ticket for a
film of this size and it's all inspiring
really what they do here and you have to
give it to the visual effects designers
especially because they are just doing
incredible work but in regards to that
third act there's something that gets
tossed around a lot in reviews and it's
usually
down upon and that's fanservice a lot of
critics like to pinpoint fanservice and
say that's bad and I've probably even
done that before but really as a creator
why would you not want to serve your
fans they're the ones who are supporting
you and paying for you and making sure
that you can continue to work so
naturally you'd want to make them feel
happy and show them things they want to
see but that's not to say this film
doesn't take risks they definitely do
with some characters and you'd have to
be a big fan of this series to know that
they're taking risks there's things that
just I did not expect and it's through
the whole movie
and you're like okay that's what they
did and for some people they might hate
it and and some might think it's
extremely awesome I don't know I thought
it was funny
I liked it I'm excited to talk about it
in a spoiler video and more on that
later
but let's talk negatives because no
movie is perfect no matter how much you
want it to be
except for alien and 12 Angry Men yeah
yeah those movies they're pretty much
perfect this film is not paced as well
as infinity war is and a lot of it is
because of that first act it is slow you
could call it a slow burn which is
probably the most you know nice way to
say that you were kind of bored for a
while and some people will probably say
that but they needed it to set up
certain things there are still a few
scenes though that do feel like they
could have been cut there are a few
specific scenes that don't really
necessarily have to be in the movie but
they're there sort of for information
sake and that's understandable again but
still there's just a little bit in that
first half hour to 40 minutes where
you're like yeah that doesn't
necessarily have to be there so it's not
paced as well as infinity war infinity
war is a movie that from beginning to
end it really feels extremely cohesive I
liked that film a lot more than when I
first reviewed it even then I really
liked it but I've really come to love
that movie and I would say just as a
pure superhero film infinity war is
probably the better movie but endgame is
more emotionally satisfying and resonant
like I did tear up an end game and I did
cry and I felt something
it definitely hit me and that's not
normal so in some ways you can look at
them in very diff
waise they're nice companion pieces with
each other and I like that I like that
this isn't just a copy and paste
infinity war it feels like they did try
to do a few things differently yes
you're going to get your massive
superhero battles I mean what do you
wanted to do fucking flip a coin and say
Oh heads I win okay and credits oh you
want to see him fucking punch people in
the face of course Jesus but within that
finale there's so much going on that it
does feel like the Russos were a little
overwhelmed because there are things
happening in the finale and I know
they're happening but we don't really
see them because there's so much that
they were like we're just gonna focus on
this part right now but but I'm like
what about that stuff no we're not
showing you that because this is
happening oh okay I get it yeah it does
sort of feel like they had things they
wanted to happen they got that shot and
said okay we got that shot now forget
about that cuz there's shit happening
over here that's cooler so it doesn't
feel quite as coherent as the massive
finale that took place in Wakanda an
infinity war although it's still like
glorious to look at and you can
absolutely nitpick the shit out of this
movie I mean you can go and watch it and
be like no that is so dumb no and just
be that person but like I'm not that
person okay
you know I go to these films to have fun
I go to these films to enjoy myself and
I did and a story I'm gonna give
Avengers endgame in a - when it comes to
things I wanted to see I saw most of
them when it comes to things that I
didn't think I was going to see most of
them I was excited about seeing so I saw
stuff and it was good
that's my extremely in-depth review of
event of Avengers I can't speak I still
have a remnant of a cold I really do
think most fans are going to enjoy this
film I'm not seeing it being an overly
divisive movie at all I think there
might be a few risks they take where
fans might be divided on it but
those are like small moments I was just
talking to a friend of mine about this
when I film is overall really good but
there's little things you didn't like
you can overlook it you're like well I
love most this movie but that one part
but you know what everything else was so
good so it's okay I'll accept it whereas
if this film was just littered with
problems I'd want to talk about all
those but when you have so much good
happening around a couple little things
you can really start to nitpick and get
like annoyingly nitpicky about and at
that point you have to ask yourself is
this worth it you know life is short go
see the movie but like I said in the
beginning of the video thank you to
Dollar Shave Club they are the sponsor
for this video and I thank them for that
they sent me this awesome box filled
with goodies in the mail which includes
dr. Carver's easy shave butter they're
hydrating daily face cleanser the razor
body and replacement blades we all have
our everyday grooming routine and for me
that's making sure that my beard looks
as good as I can make it which is
actually really hard because my skin
sucks it does like I will break out
hardcore if I use a low-quality razor
I'm not even making that up
it's been a thing since eighth grade
when I started shaving because I was
really hairy in eighth grade so just
thought you'd want to know that but
don't let their name to see you Dollar
Shave Club can solve all your grooming
needs in one box they have shower
products oral care products hair
products skin products and obviously
shaving products too right now they have
a great offer where you can get their
shave shower or oral starter set for
just five dollars each and they're gonna
send that right to your house just like
this so join the club at the link in the
description below that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash Kris stuckman
and try one of their starter sets or all
of them for just $5 each you can get
that exclusive offer at
dollarshaveclub.com slash Kris Stockman
thank you so much of them for sponsoring
this video I'm gonna be doing some
special things towards the end of the
year that I can't wait to talk to you
guys more about in an episode of my
filmmaking journey I sort of hinted at
it in the second episode but right now
I'm really excited about saving and
building up a budget for something so
I'm really grateful to the people who
have sponsored my videos and who have
helped make that possible and I can
wait to share more information about
that with you guys very soon as things
start to roll along throughout the rest
of the year guys thank you so much as
always for watching look forward to more
reviews very soon if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]